Especially among the enthusiastic,
and you might,
you might say,
well,
you should be enthusiastic.
Well,
you should be enthusiastic when
the probability reward is high,
probably as you can't tell now,
if everybody's running around doing the
probability of reward is high and you're
enthusiastic,
you're going to get caught up in that
and then everybody's going to get caught
up in it.
And then the probability of reward is
going to be high for a while until you run
out of enthusiastic people and then bang,
game over.
So
why are people like that?
While we're great mimics and the fact
that we get enthusiastic and imitate each
other,
it makes us able to cooperate.
Because like if say you're a leader,
you want it filled me with enthusiasm so
I can go off and do impossible things.
And that happens sometimes.
You know,
you can come up with some hair brained,
you know,
absurdly optimistic scheme.
Like we'll go to the moon in five
years and which is impossible,
of course.
And then everybody thinks,
oh,
that would be great.
And there's a huge movement and Poof,
you're on loan in five years.
And it was impossible.
Well,
you could say Kennedy was a
self deceiver when he said it.
You could say that,
except in retrospect,
he wasn't cause it worked.
And that was all enthusiasm too,
and a bubble in a sense
that worked.
So there's no simple
way out of these things.
It's disruptive.
And you know what happens to,
if you let your kids
have fun out of control,
sooner or later,
one of them bangs their head on a
table or falls down the stairs or gives
another kid at poker,
you know,
like it will or break
something or you know,
it isn't just that it bothers people.
It's that it's the Dionysian,
it's Dionysian danger.
It's orgastic danger and get
too enthusiastic about things.
You get into trouble.
It's not negative emotion
that drives teenage pregnancy.
It's impulsive,
positive emotion.
Right.